live entertainment is back as well at
the venetian grand canal
shops we're talking of course about
those renaissance characters alex
look at hector exciting news a lot going
on hector good morning are you joining
the ensemble
i hope to join i'm just not good enough
take a look listen this is
this is great this is great after having
a dark year
it's nice to see life coming back in
many different ways
performers finally returning to the
grand canal shops bringing life back and
we have performances that start friday
saturdays and sundays
and joining us live we have janet to
explain you know how big of a deal this
is after uh you know performing for so
many years and the pandemic rolled in
stop things and now we are making a
comeback it's
wonderful we couldn't be more proud and
honored to bring back our iconic
streetmaster cast
they're here every friday saturday and
sunday on three different stages
at grand canal shops these are great
talented performers
and you know it just really warms your
heart to listen to the music it's so
beautiful
it is it's enchanting and inspiring
and it's also free and it's family
friendly there's
no better place to have family
entertainment
than grand canal shops at the venetian
resort on that note it's coming back
just in time for
spring but also a very busy weekend
ahead of us
possibly absolutely you know grand canal
shops at the venetian resort is open 365
days a year
and so we will be open on easter sunday
and our entertainment team will be here
and again it's great after you have the
family meal
maybe you want to come down and enjoy
some free family friendly entertainment
and shop and enjoy also some of our
culinary
restaurants on property give us a little
bit of insight into
the work it takes to train for them to
train
and just learn the ropes absolutely they
go through
rigorous training and they're also
classically performing
artists so they've been classically
trained in operatic performance
and these are just some of the best of
the local entertainment that we have
and we're so proud to have them at grand
canal shops entertaining our guests
that come from all over the world and
lastly we'll be seeing them floating
around the grand canal shops at three
different locations is that correct
that's correct we put three stages in
throughout the property
that are all socially distanced and very
far from the guests so that they can
enjoy
safely all the performances and enjoy
grand canal while they're here
awesome thank you so much thanks for
having us so early so
i'm gonna try to learn just a little bit
but don't get your hopes up because
these are fantastic people i
just listen to them all right reporting
live from the grand canal shops here
inside the venetian hector mejia and
this
fantastic group back to you guys hector
don't cut yourself short
you are a talented man yeah you're a
fantastic you're up there too
there it is there it is hector mejia
he's like that all day folks four seven
renaissance
have fun hector